do you miss those days snl days or no
you know i
yeah i do because uh
because it was so well you know the what
wait you weren't in front of were you in
front of an audience
we did yeah but it was like taped it
wasn't live don't make fun of us so you
guys were like
taped right yeah we [ __ ] right like
edit
and [ __ ] we edited it right yeah yeah
anyway
right upper upper
yeah uh but uh no you were uh how what
was it it was it was i do miss it yeah
but not like oh my god i missed it
my decision leaving you know but it's uh
yeah
i do business sometimes because there's
nothing like it obviously so
because when we but it's so stressful
that what if i were to go back there
like if lauren was all of a sudden like
come back let's just be
uh spontaneous yeah i came back and i
and i was back in the cast for some
weird reason uh i'd probably be like
this is
not it's too stressful yeah very
stressful
yeah because um with us i remember
you know when we do a live sketch right
we would do a
take in front of a live audience right
but then they would give us notes
oh that's interesting too right so they
would you they would cut and then
and then you would have a bunch of
writers and producers go don't say that
line
say this right after the scene is that
right yeah so they'll give us part of
the scene no we'll do the whole sketch
right right they'd cut it right because
you would shoot it live right and then
they would give us notes
jokes you know what i mean right quick
edits
and then you would do it again right
right i can't imagine
like that's something no because you
guys just did it one time so we have a
dress rehearsal though
ah too in front of a live audience but
it's not
uh it's not a live show it's not the one
that people are going to see on
television
ah so we do have that
like how you do that yeah but we do have
uh an
opportunity to do what you did and see
if jokes work or not like it's a
two-hour show
that we do and we already know that it's
gonna be a half hour cut
wow so why right but we have that time
to uh
give notes and stuff but were you i can
only i can imagine that in the beginning
of each show
you would be i would because for me if i
was on because
being on mad tv look felt like we're on
community theater
like didn't there was no stakes it
didn't feel like the stakes were high
and it came across that way
no
that's the that's a real you by by the
way that's me yeah yeah
but um i'm such a dick but with
i can't imagine i always think too when
i was on mad going i wouldn't be able to
do
snl because just the pressure of it
you know i mean so i mean were you like
the night before
like sleepless because you were so
nervous uh
no i was more it's if you're
you know i was like if you're busy
enough you won't be
sleepless you know right right and i
usually had a pretty good show lauren
was
giving to me so and he put my stuff in
so he trusted me
right i was one of the luckier ones i
was a little bit on the upper upper
middle class
but no he was uh i got a lot of my stuff
so it wasn't as bad of
uh as stressful as uh some others may
have well who's on your uh your
generation
on the show it was one of the best i
think it was will
tina jimmy seth polar
mm-hmm uh rachel dratch uh yeah
children great molly molly yeah
gosh yeah uh bill murray chevy chase
no yeah yeah who else uh yeah it was a
good cat it was a great camera
yeah it's a that's a really good class
will arnett great
a forte i got so many wills yeah yeah
will forte
forte yeah not on it because it was like
obviously the
old school at the beginning right right
and then there was the generation you
know the
eddie murphy joe piscopo yeah that was a
little weird
that was a weird time it wasn't like so
that was like not to
be rude to the others in the cast but
that was like the eddie murphy time i
think
that's when i started watching snl
because i was like this guy is
insane it's so good yeah and that's so
fun to watch in comedy just like seeing
that guy that
just lifted the bar yeah and you're just
waiting for everyone
else to go up to that bar now yeah yeah
yeah because he's like well everybody's
gonna have to compete with this guy
because he's
so good and then you had so excited that
doesn't happen that often anymore it
doesn't
it just doesn't you know you're waiting
for who's the next hero
right yeah yeah yeah that's another to
be discussed
and then you had the dana carvey right
john lovitz
um that jennifer phil hartman right
right david spage
snyder all those guys adam sandler
dennis and then
your wave was great you know i mean so
that's what i grew up to because when i
came back
when i came from the philippines i got a
small
television we had a big television
back home we didn't have american
programs
oh my god how did you know that you said
he lost uh
something well no he made some really
bad money moves um but he comes from old
money my dad was a very
all his side of the family scrooge when
i first came the
first came to the united states i hadn't
really watched any snl growing
up because there's only a few american
programs that made it back home gary
shandling made it back home
the other things wimbledon tennis stuff
like that yeah those go hand-in-hand
yeah yeah when i came here with me
are you watching wimbledon no oh he must
be watching gary